The next line of Dimple code we have to replace, is the axis construction code.
In Dimple, this actually happens in two places.
First we added a time axis, corresponding to the year of our data,
which we made the x axis.
We also added a y axis, corresponding to the attendance for that year.
One subtlety of the X axis that we did in Dimple,
was that by specifying the parse format as only the year, Dimple automatically
aggregated all the games for a given year, and summed up their attendances.
D3 won't do this for us, but we actually may not want it to.
As we add more context to our visualization, instead of visualizing a single
year and the total attendance for that year, let's try visualizing every game.